you gotta tell the story about the ten
million dollar Saudi rig whatever you
could say about it I think that was like
the one piece of jewelry that you've
made that people are like hey we got to
hear whatever story he's got there that
he could tell with what's behind that
piece so with that story it's like no
now I'm doing everything right yeah I
think had I not made jewelry for Michael
Jackson like the sultan of brunai dr.
Phil people who were like very outside
my hip-hop demographic clients um I get
a call from somebody and every time we
go out to the nightclubs and stuff in
the late 2000s to the early 2010 11 12
this you know zombie dudes Arab guy he'd
come around and the sickest Lamborghinis
I'm talking about like super cars coming
in the hypercar hyper cars technically
anything about I think a million dollars
right and he'd have a security guard a
certain thing but he drive like in
regular clothes he's wearing his his
outfit which is with you know with with
the UM goddamn I can't think of the word
the with the headdress yeah but what
forgot the anyways um not the turbine
turns right it was yeah the whole thing
and I finally found his Instagram page I
never pushed Julianna and I think you
always do what I did and when I saw the
pager so my boy on the a man which
nobody to buy and stuff I bet to Dubai
in 2008 but I never like you know and
I've shown this picture of my boy
wearing on traditional clothes when he's
in LA he's not wearing that plus she
doesn't like being pictures being taken
him so no one ever take pictures
they'll take pictures of the car but
it's part of their culture they're not
supposed to be popping I'll be out there
boom so I didn't know he was a prince I
had to find out you know through his
Instagram page and how I found out was
the head where you know it's like red
white head bear I didn't know that there
was like patterns in it and when you
have a pattern in it those patterns mean
something it could be regulars for
regular silly whatever but if you see it
a certain way immediately anybody in Abu
Dhabi Saudi or like you know whoever
does see it
he's well that I my boy he knows that
immediately and then he goes he'll do me
a favor man because he's got card
pictures on his page okay got some crap
pictures so I show a picture of a Range
Rover and a rolls-royce and he goes bad
man he has a single-digit license plate
and he knows when you had a single did
it twist to it even slightly two or
three digit
you weren't even a regular even a police
or civilian anyone a car you could be
rich no Mercedes Benz or Rolls Royce you
have to stay at least 100 feet back from
that car even police have to stay that
they're not allowed not allowed to get
next to that car anything else they have
different different rules out there
they're royalty King right so I show
that [ __ ] one day the guy who always is
his liaison for LA was like amen he's
the it married cool man dope was gonna
happen [ __ ] you know seven billion
dollar wedding is gonna be you know
traditional and he needs a backup great
what does that mean he goes well cartier
is making his ring and I was like of
course they are what do you want me for
you know I'm saying this [ __ ] it's like
ridiculous he goes well I mean you know
you're big and you know you respects you
and you know he thinks you're pretty
cool and you do for all these people he
can't tell his mom he like so he said
bought people but or his family but you
know that's what he does on his personal
time and you know he sees what you're
making could you make something really
cool for his wife-to-be knows like yeah
man I was like in my head I might do
this one Ferguson to spend too many
dollars doesn't be like three million
dollars be money you know it's crazy and
I'm a joy for a million two billion he
hits me with a stone that he wants and I
like to think I'm the biggest thing in
the world right and then you go to these
jewelry trade shows then you realize how
ok yes I'm the biggest popular person
but when it comes to significance in the
dynamic game I am so insignificant
because people have these boots that
have 30 40 60 million dollars of
diamonds and there's like not that many
diamonds then you're like holy [ __ ] you
know like the most expensive thing in my
store and you give ammo
might be 1/4 million or 4 thousand
whatever do these people have a twin
million our diamond here 30 million here
1760 like their shitty [ __ ] is like 1.6
million like the little [ __ ] so I
reach out to somebody and I say hey man
I'm looking for this stone here it's a
pink diamond and I need to get this I
need this color this everything and the
only thing that they wanted was they
didn't want me to specifically say what
it was because it goes chin it could
kind of genetically go back to the
person whatever and I could say princess
everything else is just in it whatever
soul going on
I hit my cousin up because he's the part
of the back end that deals with the
diamond dealers and we text and he goes
all right so he calls me and I'm like
what's up man and he goes it's a joke or
did you for did you to to add an extra
number on the back end it was the first
number that's how big the diamond is I
was like no bro it's both numbers that's
the number and he goes who the [ __ ] is
it and I says it's the prince and he
goes holy [ __ ] okay let's try to forget
us out so we hit up our diamond dealer
who was got us everything like
ever-living for this stone and the guy
goes get the [ __ ] out of here I was like
no leave that stone so now I became like
a [ __ ] a whole mission to find the
stone um even the big places like like
graph Harry Winston Bank left they have
a hard time finding the stone the size
of this this thing anyways I end up
finding it I had to give somebody a
million dollars to get the diamond not
until my they got a million for finding
the diamond do you understand what I'm
trying to say to you right
so my cost on the stone which he
understands where a baby was six and a
half million so you know I made two and
a half million dollar profit just off
that ring and it was fun crazy and just
my flight there which was a [ __ ]
worst flight ever had it was right Ted
second worst flight ever had my entire
life
flew private private is cool you flying
the [ __ ] if you got a really big like
jumbo jet yeah
you're a pet if you're like in a small G
for a bit fine - like Vegas you know LA
the Seattle not bad flying to [ __ ]
Saudi Arabia is not pulling that
[ __ ] like it was terrible
refueling everything scary [ __ ] I get
there um and I delivered a stone and at
that point meet his mom I meet the King
I mean the Sheik you know and meet them
they'll see everything boom and they
were like wow this is a beautiful stone
mind you it's [ __ ] 90 something
degrees outside I'm dying I can't cover
my tattoos anymore you know I'm like
this is crazy
my head is [ __ ] clean I made sure I
everything else my earrings everything I
was wearing was super classy it's just I
had a [ __ ] button-down shirt on and
how am i growing on a take I can't do oh
don't take it if you want to really see
the could go take your shirt off you
know I mean cuz I'm like [ __ ] you
know I'm like all the way through is
that don't house are his dad pulls me
aside as I came in I really appreciate
it you know what this is amazing you
know leave your information I was like
well she has everything you know and so
the ten million dollar ring was cool he
spent ten made ours in a year with me
just on gifts for his his his family
members and [ __ ] like that so it led to
a whole different you know thing when I
go to Dubai now and I was there two
times last year was there you know a
couple times before that I enter a
restaurant let's say for it's a
zuma-zuma it's like I think zoom was bad
in Dublin was like be on high-end sushi
place and I'll be at Zuma and Dubai and
I'll order eleven her daughter the food
with like another person whatever and
then no bill will come and they just
knew and they've taken care of it I'll
go into Cipriani and Dubai which is much
nicer than the original Cipriani one
either 42nd or the one in uh you know
and Soho
it's crazy anywhere I go out there it's
like I have carte blanche it's so
amazing it's just like a it was it was
it was a dull picnic you know and to him
that's nothing like when this guy shows
me his watches he'll show me watches I
can even show John Mayer buddy
honestly I have it but remember I even
get one of the one custom bespoke
watches made by Patek Phillipe or by
Rolex these dudes are getting like and
it's notorious for studies and like even
some of the stuff they have some of the
Gucci things they have they were made by
Gucci for them and I'm like holy [ __ ]
this was a [ __ ] amazing thing being
in the right place at the right time you
know being able but if I didn't find
that diamond he was gonna get it from
somebody else probably he'd have to so
that's what she wanted and on top of
that um I would never bet his dad you
know so and I mean it was a beautiful
situation yeah